なんか
うわあビックリした
あーでもリアルだなあ
あ、こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
うわきもきもきも
あすいません取り乱してしまいました
なんだと思いますか
そうですゴリラです
完全にゴリラが人間が生きている上で会うと一番怖い生き物
なぜならアイツは知能もあるし
筋力もあるし
すごいんですよね
あとすごいバナナ食べます
そんなゴリラがもし突然家に来たら
どんなに怖いかっていうのかを
今日ちょっと試してみたいと思っております
というわけでこちら買ってみました
ゴリラグラバー
まぁ名前の通りゴリラの手ですね
いやこれでもナメてたなぁ
めっちゃ安っぽいやつだと思ったんですけど
相当リアルなんですよ
てかちゃんとちゃんとこれ毛パッパッてやれば
もっとリアルになりそう
これがそして動くんだよね
うわぁ〜
うわあ〜〜〜
え待ってこれ大丈夫か怖いのかなぁ
まぁ普通に人間でこんだけ毛むくじゃらな人っていないと思うんですよ
今からピンポンを押して誰かをここに呼ぶんですけど
でドアをこうやってガチャ
ピンポーンして誰かが来る
ドアをガチャって開ける
そっからゴリラの手がいきなり
ふぅ〜んガシッガシッ
これリアルなとこは動くからねぇ
動くからマジで怖いと思うんですよ
みんなはどういう反応をするのか
実験していきたいと思います
いやー本当にゴリラだけはいっちゃん危ないですからね
ってかうわぁ触感がすごい
触った感じの触感がマジリアル
という訳で早速仕掛けていきましょう
ではいこう
はじめ：ごめんちょっと買い出し行って来まーす
はーい
けんすけ：あ〜ぁあ！
けんすけ：あぁあぁあぁ
けんすけ：いっっっったぁ〜〜い
けんすけ：こわかったよぉ〜
はじめ：はははははｗｗ
はじめ：よぉ〜し
けんすけ：がち怖かったｗ
はじめ：あっはっはっはっはｗｗｗ
はじめ：マジで怖いほんとに
はじめ：えそんなに？
けんすけ：えやばい
けんすけ：え待って結構
はじめ：結構やばかった？けんすけ：結構やばい
やふへゐ先生：けんすけのさきび叫び声聞こえたの知ってる
(ガタッガタン)
やふへゐ：痛い？
やふへゐ：うわー
トマトクン：スリッパ借りまーす
トマトクン：誰もいないっすよー
トマトクン：うわっいった
ed
トマトクン：いったぁｗｗ
トマトクン：はははｗｗいったぁｗｗ
トマトクン：はははｗｗはははｗｗ